here he is getting ready to play
significant minutes hopefully make a
deep playoff run in ground classes he
tutored math and here he is one of the
great three-point shooters in the D now
the G League all started in the same gym
you all put that sweat equity
[Applause]
[Music]
something Goods like taste winning and
that has been where there comes in from
it goes by from to ds5 provides trying
to defend Paul was gonna take the three
the dance and Paul won't drive in fee to
the name who's got a ribbon shoe box
down picked up by chin
[Applause]
[Music]
Andre look at this I mean that is a
quick trigger right there two feet on
each side on Valentine's Day stroke
Johnson good bounce pass which strip
behind you it's right
middleman parts right-wing all the way
score give the assistant Ingram's
made a great play defensively a minute
ago if he stole the ball in gets the
assist to Josh art
in Thomas's first tonight it's in
removing inside and green with the
plumber still highly down six under a
minute to go through
no Ingram yes
[Applause]